bonsoir bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
session d'information voilà tout d'abord
ce que l'on peut retenir en ce vendredi
24 avril les chiffres de l'économie sont
meilleurs la preuve avec cette enquête
réalisée par Pôle Emploi
Île-de-France 280000 postes sont les
projets de recrutement estimés pour
cette année c'est en progression
l'association pour la promotion de la
musique à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines bien
de déposer un dossier de candidature au
Trophée de la Fondation EDF l'objectif
obtenir des subventions supplémentaires
nous faisons le point avec le président
de l'association Hervé Farge invité de
cette édition et puis une douzième
édition pour la prairiale de Montigny
qui se tiendra ce samedi et ce dimanche
à Montigny à la Ferme du Manet une
manifestation organisée par le Lion's
Club des trois villages elle est
bénéfices seront intégralement reversés
pour la lutte contre la cécité mais tout
d'abord donc une bonne nouvelle sur le
front de l'emploi 290 000 recrutements
sont anticipés cette année par Pôle
emploi en Île-de-France
290127 très exactement selon les projets
de recrutement recensés 6 700 employeurs
ont répondu aux questionnaire et pour
2015 17,8% des établissements
franciliens projettent de recruter des
salariés soit plus 1,1% par rapport à
2014 les Yvelines mais également Paris
et les Hauts-de-Seine représente
61,5% de ses projets de recrutement
essentiellement dans le tertiaire dans
les services scientifiques et techniques
et techniques services aux particuliers
informations communication santé action
sociale et les métiers des services à la
personne ont été jugés à 60% les plus
difficiles à recruter donc voilà des
perspectives pour les personnes en
recherche d'emploi un autre sujet le
Réseau Sortir du Nucléaire n'oublie pas
ce triste anniversaire de Tchernobyl
c'était il y a 29 ans à cette occasion
le réseau appel à l'organisation
d'action partout en France en hommage
aux milliers de victimes de la plus
grande catastrophe environnementale et
sanitaire en Europe la manifestation une
manifestation est organisée
ce samedi à 50 ans en Yvelines le point
de rendez-vous est fixé à 11 heures
devant l'immeuble Edison de Guyancourt
et les participants seront donc ensuite
devant le site d'Areva à Montigny pour y
déposer une gerbe à la mémoire de toutes
les victimes du nucléaire d'ailleurs
est-ce que le nucléaire vous inquiète
c'est la question que nous sommes allés
vous poser dans les rues de
Saint-Quentin voici vos réponses il est
bien encadré je trouve
non ça ne m'inquiète pas peut-être si
j'en avais une à côté je dirais
peut-être pas la même chose
pour pour les générations futures il
faut que qu'on préserve notre planète
notre pays moi je suis tout à fait pour
le nucléaire déjà d'une part parce que
ça supprime énormément
de travail à toutes ces personnes qui
habitent l'argent les gens n'aiment pas
et puis je vois pas pourquoi ça
s'admirait plus qu'autre chose c'est
très dangereux bien sûr mais il y a pire
que ça on en a besoin par rapport à
l'énergie qu'on consomme et oui si c'est
pas encore
allez un tout autre sujet maintenant
pour continuer cette édition
l'association pour la promotion de la
musique à 50 ans on y vient déposer un
dossier de candidature au Trophée de la
Fondation EDF le but obtenir évidemment
une subvention supplémentaire et pour en
parler en plateau avec nous dans le
journal Hervé Farge bonsoir vous êtes
président de la pmsq alors d'abord
pourquoi avoir participé à ce concours
c'est une première c'est une première
oui effectivement puisque nous avons
donc notre action est financée en partie
par la Communauté d'Agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines en partie par
et en grande partie aussi par la ville
de Trappes en Yvelines et nous avons des
subventions qui baissent notamment côté
de l'accès de la politique de la ville
de l'État
si on veut continuer notre action on a
en plus des mécénats qui baissent on a
eu le mécénat musical Société Générale
qui nous a soutenu pendant 7 ans mais là
il faut un peu laisser la place à
d'autres donc ça s'arrête cette année
qui nous fait 25000 euros de moins et
nous avons gagné le concours HSBC l'an
dernier qui nous a permis d'avoir 15000
euros de subventions cette année mais
l'année prochaine ça va baisser et ainsi
de suite et donc comme on veut continuer
notre action dans ces cas-là tout le
monde cherche un peu de la fête on en
avait beaucoup dans le privé c'est ce
que je voulais un peu dire au niveau des
banques et voilà tout à fait et du coup
alors la participation à ce à ce trophée
ça se passe comment alors le principe
c'est comment on peut faire surtout pour
aider à nous aider tout à fait alors
d'abord c'est sur le sujet des enfants
en scène ce que l'on développe depuis
2003 on a fait un peu un bilan depuis
l'année 2003 on a eu en fait
3850 enfants de l'agglomération de 50
ans en Yvelines de toutes les villes un
trap la verrière Montigny Élancourt
enfin les sept communes qui ont
participé à ces opéras donc il chante
sur la scène de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines des opéras
comme Traviata etc et puis le public
donc leurs parents leur famille ça
permet à des familles d'accéder au
théâtre et puisqu'on donne ce spectacle
au Théâtre de 50 ans en Yvelines
et de parents et du coup
pour participer en fait le site internet
où on peut aller chez vous exactement
voilà exactement alors il y a en fait
plusieurs prix il y a un prix qui est
donné par un jury et puis il y a ce
qu'on appelle le prix du public et là le
prix du du public ce sont des gens qui
vont cliquer sur un site alors le plus
simple c'est de cliquer sur cette
Fondation
EDF Fondation EDF donc du coup le but
c'est il faut on va sur le site on
clique alors on va sur le site on clique
une fois que vous avez cliqué on vous
mettez votre mail évidemment parce que
sinon ce sera un peu facile et à ce
moment-là on vous renvoie le mail et
vous donner vous cliquez pour confirmer
votre vote et
la l'association aura le plus de votes
en France gagner et c'est une subvention
supplémentaire de 10000 euros qui serait
la bienvenue pour l'accès que nous
allons mener c'est vraiment très très
important pour nous et pour deux raisons
déjà la l'argent entre guillemets la
dimension et d'autre part l'image parce
que il y a encore beaucoup de gens qui
considèrent que faire la musique
classique à Trappes et 50 ans en
Yvelines c'est un peu ridicule c'est du
luxe et de l'élitisme alors que là vous
avez les petits enfants de Trappes en ce
moment ils sont en train de travailler
l'opéra Hansel et Gretel qui va être
donné au mois de juin sa chambre de
l'Opéra dans les rues de Trappes en ce
moment si vous vous baladez
effectivement on peut vous aider il faut
aller sur le site de
trop point
edf/s
pour la musique
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines aller sur le
site de trophées fondations voilà ça
s'afficher parfait et l'autre solution
qui est encore la plus simple c'est
d'aller sur notre site ou évidemment
nous avons un renvoi donc c'est
www.musique
parce que il se clôture le 4 mai à
minuit le 4 mai minuit alors nous on en
est en ce moment on a le compteur à 320
vous voyez c'est le Téléthon
et pour l'instant il y a déjà des gens
qui sont à
1632 donc on a vraiment besoin d'un gros
soutien si on veut que 50 ans en
Yvelines
dans la même catégorie il y en a 237
mais le concours et sur toutes les
associations confondues c'est pas
uniquement pour les accessiations
alors certains en ont 1600
il y en a qu'une pour l'instant donc il
faut aller cliquer très vite très fort
voilà et puis faire la chaîne auprès de
tous vos amis de tous vos voilà faire
fonctionner la chaîne qui est celle-là
vertueuse et
nonarité pour que l'association puisse
percevoir cette subvention de 10000
euros dont on comprend l'importance
puisque on sait que les subventions
pèsent pour les associations c'est pas
que pour la vôtre mais aussi d'autres
sont confirmés quelle est l'actualité de
la pmsq année pour les prochains mois
alors déjà pour les prochains mois
actuellement nous avons la maîtrise de
Trappes qui part lundi matin en stage
c'est un stage qui est financé par la
mairie de Trappes par notamment le
soutien de Guy Malandain et donc là ça
va se passer à la Maison du beuverie
donc il y a un groupe enfants qui va
pendant 15 jours huit jours pardon
travailler le chant ils vont être tous
ensemble et c'est quelque chose d'absion
extraordinaire parce que ça saoule de
groupe et ça leur permet de faire des
progrès vraiment très très importants
tout ça sous la conduite de Gabriela
reichner qui est une personne assez
passionnante elle a elle a travaillé
avec un compositeur hongrois qui
s'appelle Caudalie codaï dans dans la
présentation hongrois qui a développé
une nouvelle méthode d'enseignement de
la musique ce qui permet aux enfants de
faire des progrès très rapidement
contrairement en gros pour résumer si on
n'a pas fait tous les cours de solfège
qui sont des fois un peu longs assimilés
absolument il faut être patient là il
faut être codage ou Caudalie en fonction
qu'on le dise à la française ou à
l'angoisse en tout cas la méthode
c'est une méthode qui permet
d'apprendre la musique de façon simple
pour ceux qui savent c'est un petit peu
comme les méthodes Montessori pour
l'enseignement de la lecture et
d'écriture et ça marche et puis ça
marche extraordinaire les hauts lieux si
vous voulez le principe c'est que les
enfants ils apprennent d'abord à
comprendre leurs parents ensuite à
parler ils apprennent à lire ils
apprennent à écrire et ben l'idée c'est
que ils apprennent à entendre la musique
et ils apprennent à la chanter et après
ils passent à l'écrire et la lire vous
voyez c'est la même démarche naturelle
que pour un petit enfant et donc on ne
rappellera pas assez que la pmsq œuvre
depuis 15 ans au service de la musique
et surtout dans les quartiers difficiles
que l'ensemble des populations et les
jeunes qui ont pas forcément accès
naturellement à cette musique classique
puisse y accéder et c'est une très belle
action qui se passe du côté de Trappes
notamment voilà donc si vous voulez
soutenir je ne sais plus comment faire
de la peau
qui est très belle et qui mérite d'être
encouragé vous pouvez donc aller sur le
site de la Fondation EDF les Trophées de
la Fondation EDF et surtout cliquer et
ça permettra l'association d'avoir des
subventions pour continuer vos actions
merci beaucoup référence de passer sur
le plateau du journal allez autre
candidat parce qu'il n'y a pas que la
culture il y a aussi l'économie autre
candidat également pour ses trophées de
la Fondation EDF donc mais dans un autre
domaine c'est le face sont directeur
était d'ailleurs l'invité ce jeudi de
l'émission philécho il revient justement
sur l'importance de ces trophées et de
ses subventions
le principe c'est effectivement
d'accompagner des jeunes donc on
accompagne chaque année entre 10 et 15
jeunes donc on a effectivement une
personne en interne qui conduit cette
opération sachant que c'est une
opération qui est sur un coup de
fonctionnement relativement limité
néanmoins il faut effectivement tu aies
des ressources pour pouvoir développer
cette cette action donc nous l'idée au
travers de ce concours de la Fondation
EDF c'est aussi de valoriser cette
opération puisque c'est une fiction
c'est une opération qui marche très bien
qui concilie à la fois tutorat
professionnel donc des marches aussi
portées par les entreprises du
territoire et puis tu te rends sportif
donc ça porte aussi un élan sur le
territoire en faveur des des jeunes et
donc nous c'est là dessus aussi qu'on
porte le message
pour accompagner une dizaine de jeunes
je sais pas c'est 10000 euros c'est plus
est-ce que c'est chiffrable vraiment
nous lorsqu'on dépose des appels à
projets on fait effectivement une
demande de financement ensuite qui va
varier en fonction des objectifs c'est à
dire que on n'a pas le même coup si
effectivement on a un objectif
d'accompagner qu'un jeune que si on a un
objectif d'accompagner 51 jeunes par
exemple donc on va aussi moduler la
demande de financement par rapport à
l'objectif qui est fixé qu'est-ce que
vous dites aux entreprises voilà pour
leur demander de vous aider de vous
financer quel argument vous essayez de
mettre en valeur nous ce qu'on leur dit
c'est que c'est un club d'entreprise
donc on a aujourd'hui une cinquantaine
d'entreprises impliquées au niveau du
club nous on a aussi une démarche
d'aller à la rencontre d'autres
entreprises du territoire puisqu'on a
l'avantage d'avoir un tissu économique
assez dense sur le territoire de 50 ans
en Yvelines donc nous le message qu'on
va porter c'est effectivement que
l'entreprise va pouvoir participer de
manière très concrète à des opérations
au niveau de l'emploi au niveau des
jeunes du lien école l'entreprise et que
c'est aussi un levier managérial
allez on va rester dans le domaine de la
solidarité la 12e édition de la
prairiale c'est ce samedi et ce dimanche
à la Ferme du Manet de Montigny c'est
l'occasion vous le savez d'acheter des
fleurs des plantes mais pas seulement et
pour en parler Frédéric Pellegrin
bonsoir vous êtes le président des trois
villages organisateur de la
manifestation alors je l'ai dit le
principe real bien sûr c'est de pouvoir
acheter des fleurs et des plantes et des
fleurs exactement exactement c'est le
nerf de la guerre entre guillemets bon
sachant qu'on joint l'utile et
l'agréable agréable c'est bien sûr le
cadre de la Ferme du Manet qui est
toujours appréciée de tous les visiteurs
même nous organisateurs c'est un réel
plaisir de d'y organiser cet événement
là et puis l'utile c'est bien sûr
récolter quelques fonds de la part des
exposants qui viennent là en nous en
payant concrètement leur stand mais
aussi le visiteur qui laisse de 2,50 €
exactement
à la rentrée à l'entrée pardon le but
étant de
fournir un fond à destination de l'école
de chien guide d'aveugle on en reparlera
mais d'abord on va parler des
professionnels combien de personnes
combien de temps pour ces prairiales
cette année alors cette année 12e
édition nous avons environ 50 stands
nous avons une douzaine une quinzaine de
spécialistes dans plantes justement
plantes fleurs vivaces arbuste
paysagistes ainsi de suite et puis aussi
on a quelques artisans alors artisans
d'art et artisans dit de bouche jantes
alimentaires un peu spécialisé et d'où
viennent ces artisans ils viennent pas
que des Yvelines non pas du tout non non
certains sont vraiment des fidèles et
peuvent venir de très loin nous avons
des personnes qui viennent d'Alsace par
exemple ou encore de la région Centre de
la France et donc on a affaire à un
rayonnement
régional au niveau de des fournisseurs
il y a une sélection entre guillemets
les exposants c'est à dire que les gens
déposent un dossier c'est vous qui les
choisissez ou alors il voulait
les artisans qui amènent un peu de
nourriture est-ce que c'est c'est un peu
enfin leur sélectionné mais en fait vous
faites un peu attention ce soit des
produits naturels un peu exactement tout
à fait on essaye de
la connaissance oui tout à fait ça a été
depuis l'origine même du mouvement Lyon
a une affection une attention
particulière portée sur les maladies et
les problèmes des malvoyants et cette
action-là prairiale de notre club de
Montigny les trois villages porte
justement sur cette accompagnement des
malvoyants en l'occurrence donc depuis
de nombreuses années nous offrons un don
qui est quelques milliers d'euros par an
qui consiste à former et à offrir
ensuite un chien à un malvoyant combien
d'actions ont pu être combien de chiens
par exemple on peut être comme ça
financé entre guillemets grâce à la
prière ou alors concrètement on doit
être à peu près à notre 4e chien fiancé
sachant qu'un chien en formation depuis
son éducation jusqu'à sa retraite
puisque il a droit aussi une retraite
et donc organisée et le financement est
estimé grosso modo à 15000 euros donc ça
veut dire en gros pour aller pour faire
le calcul vite fait ça fait 60000 euros
qui ont FC été reversés elle a lutte
contre la cécité quelles sont les autres
actions qui sont mises en place par le
horoscope des trois villages en dehors
de cette opération des praires ou c'est
où ça mobilise tout votre énergie durant
l'année non non on a différentes actions
alors il y a des actions qui sont
strictement locales c'est-à-dire nous
avons un salon de l'art qui se déroule
en automne qui s'appelle Armanet nous
avons aussi des des actions qui se font
régulièrement chaque année que les
personnes connaissent que tout le monde
connaît le Téléthon la Banque
Alimentaire nous y participons soit en
récoltant par exemple pour la Banque
alimentaire sur voisin de Bretonneux les
fameux cartons que nous expédions sur la
région parisienne en entrepôt ou alors
au niveau du Téléthon c'est donc une
participation au centre téléphonique à
Vélizy en l'occurrence vous nous trouvez
au bout du fil au 36-37 tout simplement
combien de d'adhérents Lyon ce club de
trois villages nous sommes une quinzaine
d'adhérents très motivés mais c'est vrai
que les bonnes volontés sont les
bienvenus pour mettre tout ça en place
une action comme la prairiale et des
marais depuis à peu près 4 mois et donc
tous les trimestres on relance une
grosse action comme ça tout simplement
merci beaucoup Frédéric sur le plateau
du journal et donc je rappelle la
prairiale c'est à la Ferme du Manet de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux 12e édition donc
ce samedi ce dimanche voilà si vous
voulez acheter des fleurs et des plantes
elles sont toujours très belles et si en
plus vous voulez faire une bonne action
pour la lutte contre la cécité merci
beaucoup d'être du journal on va
poursuivre cette émission avec comme
tous les vendredis un retour sur
l'actualité de la semaine écoulée
la liste d'Alexandra Rosetti sans
surprise arrivait très largement en tête
du second tour de la municipale partiel
de Voisins-le-Bretonneux élection qui
s'était déroulée après l'annulation par
le Conseil d'états fin février
l'ancienne mère adjointe dans cette
merde pardon sortant entre élu dimanche
dernier était l'invité du journal ce
lundi nous lui avons demandé quelles
conséquence ces deux mois de vacances du
pouvoir pouvaient avoir sur les dossiers
de la ville on l'écoute de mon
interruption c'est pas anodin alors
c'est pas non plus gravissime mais c'est
pas anodin parce que alors ce qui
m'inquiète le plus dans ce que je vais
retrouver là c'est par rapport aux
travaux je pense en particulier aux
travaux qu'on fait dans les écoles en
été voilà là j'ai cette question est-ce
que on est encore dans les temps pour
lancer des appels d'offres pour les
pouvoirs les démarrer dans les temps
est-ce que les entreprises seront
toujours disponibles on a aussi des
maîtrises d'oeuvre à attribuer pour des
rénovations des réhabilitations en
rapport avec un contrat au départemental
donc c'est ces questions là
bon après on aura un délai effectivement
on sera au-delà déréglementaires pour la
taxe d'enlèvement des ordures ménagères
mais ça c'est comme comme le budget de
la communauté
d'agglomérations
c'est celui du gymnase effectivement où
il y a une partie qui devait être fait
cet été qui sera faite en juillet 2016
mais étant donné que tous les élus ont
déjà siéger connaissent bien leur
dossier je pense que les choses vont
démarrer vraiment très vite allez un
maire peut en cacher un autre mais oui
Henri pailleux a démissionné de la
mairie de Coignières c'est Jean-Pierre
Sauvestre son ancien ma mère adjoint aux
affaires économiques qui ont repris le
flambeau il est à l'invité du journal de
jeudi le changement dans la continuité
mais je suis dans la continuité dans la
continuité de l'action d'Henri Payet
depuis de nombreuses années et si
j'étais dans son équipe effectivement
bien sûr bien sûr nous nous sommes
engagés en 2014 sur un programme et je
vais continuer bien sûr ce programme
puisque nous sommes engagés vis-à-vis
des Coignières et notamment la
rénovation du gymnase qui doit
intervenir rapidement et également le
réaménagement du centre village et
notamment pour ce qui concerne le
parking notamment nous avons un parking
en étage qui est
inutilisée pour des raisons de sécurité
et il nous faut absolument voir évoluer
cette affaire je tiens à conserver à
Coignières la notion de petites villes à
taille humaine je ne souhaite pas
transformer Coignières comme une ville
seulement
urbaine si vous voulez nous sommes tout
de même une ville avec une grande partie
de zone
et l'esprit village l'esprit village
l'esprit de vivre ensemble l'esprit de
bien-être et l'esprit de services
également de proximité
ils viennent à la rencontre des
populations de mal logées le Samu Social
de Paris déplace exceptionnellement ces
équipes dont plusieurs départements ce
mois-ci les Yvelines étaient concernées
un reportage de Mathilde Capvern et
Élodie moine
originaire de la Côte d'Ivoire Aïssata
vit en France depuis deux ans comme
36000 personnes en Île-de-France elle
était hébergée à l'hôtel en situation
précaire l'accès aux droits et à la
santé devient difficile beaucoup de
problèmes que on a on a
ici en France ici c'est ça on vient ici
pour pour parler problème de papier
problème de travail tout pour la santé
tout ça
le Samu Social de Paris propose un
accueil aux familles à bord d'un bus
l'avantage de cette démarche la
proximité ils y établissent un
diagnostic sanitaire et social sans
rendez-vous on s'est rendu compte que
les familles étaient très isolées parce
que souvent elles sont hébergées en
grande banlieue et enfin grande couronne
et c'est assez difficile parce que elles
ont leur démarche par exemple sur Paris
donc à chaque démarche il faut qu'elle
se déplace sur Paris et de fait de
pouvoir leur proposer des services qui
sont à proximité de leur hôtel déjà ça
leur permet de faire un point de savoir
un peu ce qu'elles peuvent entreprendre
que ça soit au niveau du sanitaire ou du
social le but est composé d'une équipe
de 5 tous salariés à plein temps les
familles sont accueillies par un
chauffeur celui-ci prend les premières
informations avant de les rediriger vers
l'assistante sociale l'infirmière ou le
médecin on part de la demande de la
famille qui nous explique ces
difficultés et à partir de là en
fonction on voit avec elle en fonction
de elle ce qu'elle peut faire de son
autonomie
de ses repères quelle orientation peut
proposer pour répondre à sa difficulté
sur le 78 il y a beaucoup de personnes
qui sont au sens sécurité sociale donc
ils peuvent pas accéder aux soins parce
qu'ils ont pas de couverture maladie et
là on se rend compte que il y a de
réelles difficultés par rapport à ça en
moyenne 5 à 10 familles sont reçus par
jour depuis un an le bus voyage en Île
de France il stationnera dans les
Yvelines jusqu'à la fin du mois de mai
et on termine ce journal avec la visite
de la cour des senteurs à Versailles par
des adhérents de l'association Valentin
à Huy ces personnes malvoyantes ont
exploré leur sens olfactif grâce à de
nouveaux outils sensoriels mis en place
notamment par des élèves versaillais
es jusqu’à une jardinière en béton
visiter un lieu quand on est déficient
visuelle ce n'est pas toujours aisé ce
jour-là plusieurs adhérents de
l'association Valentin lui teste divers
outils celui-ci est une application
également sur votre écran pour avoir des
informations sur le jardin
les grosses difficultés c'est déjà
d'accéder
extérieurement parlant
au lieu j'entends par exemple on est ici
à Versailles accéder au démarrage d'une
visite d'un château c'est excessivement
difficile parce qu'on a cette grande
place par exemple la place d'Armes moi
je suis incapable de me débrouiller seul
sur la place d'Armes c'est impossible
j'ai un guidage Audi on trouvait que la
nouvelle technologie permettait de le
faire facilement grâce à des balises qui
utilisent la technologie à bacon ou
Bluetooth flow énergie autre outil des
plantes tactiles ils ont été imaginés
par 6 lycéens de Notre-Dame du grand
champ lors de la ratelier de terminale
pendant six mois a raison de deux heures
par semaine mais aussi lorsqu'il le
souhaitait ces jeunes ont travaillé en
collaboration avec l'association ils ont
aucun moyen de voir du coup ça leur
permet que leurs doigts d'avoir déjà une
vision globale de où est-ce qu'il faut
aller quel chemin il faut suivre s'il
faut aller à droite ou à gauche au nord
au sud donc c'est vraiment une vision
globale ces plantes l'important c'était
que en fait tout a été fabriqué ici par
les étudiants on va dire qu'on les a un
peu encadrés qu'on a un peu modifié
ensemble de choses et c'est l'imprimerie
de AVH qui a imprimé ses plans donc ces
plans sont aujourd'hui tout à fait
valables tout à fait intéressant et je
peux vous assurer que quand un déficient
visuel parcourt ses plans pendant une
demi-heure ensuite il a tout à fait dans
son imaginaire le trajet qui va pouvoir
parcourir et il sait se représenter
ensuite mentalement totalement le trajet
l'association Valentin lui regroupe 400
personnes dont 200 déficients visuel
aveugle ou malvoyants et 180 bénévoles
la découverte de la cour des senteurs
était une phase de test l'association
espère cependant l'avoir se généraliser
selon les matins terminés merci d'avoir
suivi l'information revient en direct
lundi à 18h en plateau avec nous
Francine Christophe yvelinoise ancienne
déporté et elle reviendra pour nous sur
l'importance de la journée de
commémoration du 26 avril je vous
souhaite un excellent weekend